we were talking last week about new
disclosures that Trump's former now
disgraced national security adviser
Michael Flynn had been paid over half a
million dollars to basically lobby for
the Turkish government at one point to
help the Turkish government investigate
the 2016 coup attempt against President
Erdogan and of course we now know that
Michael Flynn resigned in shame from his
White House position last month after it
was discovered that he had been lying
about his communications with Russia
while working for the Trump campaign
we've now were filling in the color now
we've learned about one specific way in
which Michael Flynn was involved as a
representative of Turkey and I have
video and audio of former CIA director
james Woolsey who is accusing Michael
Flynn of talking to the Turkish
government last fall about trying to
help them secretly kidnap one of turkish
President Erdogan political opponents
who was living in the United States okay
listen to what james woolsey said i
showed up and there were several turks
and several americans there there was
some discussion serious discussion of
finding some way to move mr. Gulen out
of the United States to Turkey you might
call it brain storming but it was
brainstorming about a very serious
matter that would pretty clearly be a
violation of law
so how would Woolsey know this at the
time he was an advisory board member of
Michael Flynn's company and Flynn asked
him to be at the meeting which was held
at a hotel in New York City Woolsey says
that he walked into the room Michael
Flynn is in there with top-level Turkish
government officials including Turkey's
foreign minister and what they were
trying to figure out was how to remove
Turkish cleric Fethullah Glen from the
US without anybody knowing which would
by the way illegally bypassed the
extradition process that exists in the
United States Woolsey said he later
notified Vice President Biden about the
conversation the man that they were
allegedly talking about removing from
the country Fethullah Gulen is an
opponent of President
Dajuan and i we can only imagine what
would have happened to him if rwan had
gotten his hands on him within Turkey's
borders Michael Flynn was reportedly
working against the u.s. trying to
figure out a way to illegally turn
someone who was here legally over to a
foreign power do you understand the
magnitude of this I I don't know how to
put into words Pat how incredible this
is and it seems completely credible
because we're hearing from james Woolsey
who has no reason whatsoever to lie
about this especially at this point we
know that Michael Flynn is completely
out of his mind and I think more
revelations will come out once the
Russian investigation is complete but
we've known this because even in the RNC
he would call for a Hillary Clinton to
be locked up and you could just see the
passion and despite these sketchy ties
that he has and despite the issues he
obviously has going on is in his head
Donald Trump is like yeah I want this
guy on my team I want him to be my
national security adviser that's my
thought which is this tells us a lot
about the type of people that Donald
Trump is willing to appoint to the
highest most sensitive positions of
power in the US
Trump hired someone who tried to break
us law to benefit foreign dictators uh
you you almost can't put into words how
extreme this is and the sad thing is
that even after all of this we know that
Republicans will continue to focus more
on how are we learning about lots of the
crazy things that Trump is doing rather
than focusing on what it's exposing
about Trump and his associates and there
are now rumors that Flynn may have made
a deal with the FBI there's actually a
tweet from national security expert
Juliette Khayyam who said from my
sources and what has been openly
reported it increasingly looks like
Flynn may have a deal with the FBI this
is the possible silver lining pad which
is Flynn may be in so much trouble that
he may turn the equivalent of state's
witness in this case we're talking about
the federal government rather than that
then a state prosecuting agency as the
term often suggests and if that's true
then whatever they
Vaughn Flynn must be really bad because
to get him if it's true to testify to
the potential crimes of the Trump
administration he must really be in some
deep you know what well he absolutely
should show up and testify that's what
Paul mana forts going to do
that's what Carter page is going to do
and Roger stone as we've learned this
week I look forward to it and by the way
a Roger stone scheduled to be on this
program upcoming I normally don't tease
interviews ahead of time because he
might cancel whatever as of now we have
an interview scheduled with Roger stone
we will see if it happens